Mammoth Lakes is a town entombed by a
snowpack three times the historical
average
in the space of several months
California has swung from severe drought
to extreme winter storms
this is what that looks like in the
mountains everything here is buried
for the skiers and snowboarders it's a
boon
but the locals it's a slow-motion
disaster I just um collapsed it wasn't
even an explosion
belly a house here is undamaged
Steve's own home has become an igloo of
sorts we just now got sunlight in here
it's so heartbreaking many many
countless homes are going to take on
water over
um you know months it's like being
squeezed by an anaconda
and we kept screaming help us um nobody
cut the damn head off
here no this is a
is it the worst
income
because these walls with the rising
temperatures are starting to melt
and they're sending torrents of water
Downstream
the snow-capped mountains are a specter
of Doom in California's Central Valley
near record rainfall has already seen
The Rebirth of Tulare Lake for the first
time in decades this was dry land
beneath the waves Acres of farmland
Tulare Lake hasn't just been resurrected
it's reappeared with a Vengeance it now
covers 30 square miles resembling a vast
Inland sea and over the next couple of
months this could grow to 200 square
miles
or whatever was planted there is is gone
it's been destroyed bulb has already
lost 900 Acres of Farmland to the lake
now he's worried the Deluge from the
snowmelt could threaten his 20 000
cattle too it is very very serious this
this is an historic event we were in
such a severe drought here in California
so you know you you pray for the rain
and now all of a sudden you're praying
for it not to rain and you're praying
for it to be cool to where the snow melt
doesn't come down all at one time
this is now a disaster Zone and the
state's Governor is under pressure to
shore up defenses there's not a climate
expert you know there's not a
meteorologist that doesn't say the
following we've never seen this at this
level of intensity in extreme do you
wonder what has to happen
to believe in climate change I just uh
visit California
is emerging from a decade of drought to
different extreme weather the golden
state has now become the southern state
with even more water on the way and for
people here that is a terrifying
Prospect Martha callner Sky News
California's Central Valley